chaque vendredi nous consacrons quelques
instants de ce journal à l'homme ou à la
femme de la semaine aujourd'hui soeur
emmanuelle que tout le monde connaît
pour son action en faveur des plus
défavorisés que ce soit en egypte au
soudan par exemple
bonsoir soeur emmanuelle vous n'êtes pas
à bruxelles ce soir et alors da tout
d'abord j'ai appris que vous alliez
avoir 80 ans la semaine prochaine alors
permettez nous de vous souhaiter un
excellent anniversaire
merci très bas mais surtout grâce à vous
nous allons pouvoir reparler du soudan
c'est un pays où en ce moment des
milliers des milliers de personnes sont
en train de mourir vous avez été l'une
des premières à lancer un appel en
faveur de ces populations contre ce
génocide est ce que vous avez
l'impression que votre appel comme en
fait entendu du côté du soudan comme du
côté des nations de la france en
particulier
il ya quelque chose qui bouge el
hamdoulilah grâce à dieu mais peut même
vous aviez vous souhaitiez lancé un
nouvel appel ce soir c'est à dire voyez
vous que voilà j'ai donc 80 gens je suis
une vieille femme née une vieille femme
qui malheureusement dans sa vie dans sa
vie a vu trop de morts trop de violence
entre deux êtres de faim et je voudrais
crier crier au monde à tous ceux qui
l'écoutent
je voudrais les supplier faisons la paix
paix entre nations paix entre individus
paix que les opus se regardent et se
regarder j'écoutais ce sourire gêné la
main dans la main afin qu'il y ait plus
d'enfants qui meurent de faim et qui
meurent parce que leurs parents se tue
alors justement que peut-on faire je
reprends l'exemple du soudan que vous
connaissez bien
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire dans ce pays
on a déjà alerté beaucoup l'opinion mais
quand on sait par exemple que même les
organisations humanitaires ont beaucoup
de mal à l'aise sur place je ne dis pas
mais on arrive et j'ai vu m'amène à quel
point au soudan même le soudan du nord
qui ne souffre pas que monsieur on est
préoccupés de sauver tant et tant
d'enfants tant et tant de réfugiés par
milliers avant et personnellement wasa
tant d'amis je peux actuellement nourrir
28 enfants grâce d'ailleurs âge
delors et au marché commun qui mène donc
je suis plein d'espoir et je dis à tous
espérons et dont nous aimons merci soeur
emmanuelle merci beaucoup